in the lobby of Ramsey solutions right
here in orange wood Tennessee nikki is
with us hi Nikki how are you I'm awesome
super glad to be here we're honored to
have you are you from Nashville Oh your
neighbor then yeah very cool well
welcome I am here to do your debt-free
scream yes I love it how much have you
paid off forty thousand seven hundred
dollars love it and how long did that
take 14 months good for you and your
range of income during that time it
stayed the same it was thirty thousand a
year right okay so you must have sold
something I bid what you say I sold my
Honda my own seven thousand on it and I
pay I sold it for thirteen thousand so
that was a big chunk towards the debt
mm-hmm
the love of my life Kirby went here we
bought and sold some cars so we did some
flips mm-hmm
with a divorce I had $100 pretty much
kind of not alimony but to make the debt
equitable hundred other payment so that
was about $1,000 mm-hmm I was given the
government alone hundred dollars a month
so I got a tax refund of about fourteen
uh-huh and I sold a bunch of stuff on
eBay I was in banking for 12 years and I
had suits and shoes and nice clothes and
I bought them all at thrift stores for
about six dollars and sold the money of
it for about 45 so write a bunch of
stuff good for you yeah very cool very
cool
so you sold a bunch of stuff you've also
been working your butt off yes I mean
over time yes I didn't mention that like
side jobs and just I mean eliminate
clock in addition to the 30 yes okay
yeah because that's just my salary
gotcha okay what do you do for a living
I'm office manager for a team went
customs we restore cars Oh neat fun okay
that's the car plan that makes any car
plan right
so forty-one thousand dollars worth of
debt some of it was the Honda what was
the rest of it um can I go until some
little backstory there sure okay so ten
years ago I made the biggest mistake of
my life and I'm married a horrible man
horrible marriage ten years it started
probably the next day
I didn't know that he hadn't filed taxes
in four years and he hadn't paid rent on
the house that I moved into in two
months or had the security deposit so
when I married him I was like the most
reasons why people get divorces money
and I'd never had that in my life I had
$10,000 in the bank I'm like there's no
way we're gonna have any problems I had
tenure that's not a lot of money but I
had ten grand
yeah well that disappeared in a week and
then I got a credit card offer in the
mail for Home Depot we went to Home
Depot $7,000 on a home depot credit card
we had a point two-five lon but of
course we needed a $5,000 zero turn lawn
mower then we needed a $5,000 or a
$2,000 shed they we needed a trailer
they we needed to pack black blower then
we mean it just goes on it ends up
getting a trailer in a truck mm-hmm so
that was my life it was horrible but all
that debt is from living on credit cards
and of course a family loan for about
4,300 because he probably worked a year
out of that nine and a half year
marriage you stayed with him a long time
I did like ten years too long
yeah gosh bless your heart I had enough
is that what happened 14 months ago the
divorce was final the divorce was final
yes sir and I had I worked for the bank
before I started working for a Kirby
who's the love of my life by the way and
I had saved up a couple thousand and
he'd been listening to you for years you
know he was on your plan he's that free
he owns five cars he owned is his boat
and I had a couple thousand and I was
like what do I do with it you know and
he said put a thousand dollars aside
dump the rest it on a credit card and
that's what I did I paid up the first
one and that's what just started the
snowball rolling I sold my Honda got
that payment that 300 payment gone the
insurance payment gone because we
commute to work together mm-hmm
and so and he also helped me out a lot
with food and shelter so he's like I'm
gonna live here anyway and have to pay
this anyway so you just put all your
money towards that very good very cool
good for you way to go thank you
way to go how's it feel do you know I'm
because they'll intense about getting my
emergency fund fully funded you know so
I'm just still putting money aside but
it's just so so weird that morning I
woke up and I'd made the last payment I
was like my money doesn't have to go
anywhere going to somebody else right
that's very cool
so when people hear you paid off
fourteen thousand forty-one thousand
dollars in 14 months and they say how
did you do that what do you tell them
the secret was for you getting out of
debt I never bought anything I mean I I
think I lived on maybe fifty dollars a
month that's just for necessities like
toothpaste and that kind of thing
I didn't put any money out for anything
and this is funny I mean I didn't buy
socks for probably two years my socks
were down to the mesh you know I would
sew up my clothes and one of the hard
parts T was sitting there on the couch
on well the night so we head off and I'm
so went up my underwear because I didn't
want to buy them you know just I saved
every single penny finally when I paid
it off his mom gave you a $10 gift card
to one of the stores that was you know
no minimum ten dollars office like heck
yeah it sucks that's awesome
so not buy anything you sold everything
inside it was you said you work some
extra jobs what was the work it was oh
sorry go ahead
was it all working extra jobs at that
one place it was okay oh all right very
good well good for you Nikki I'm proud
of you thank you congratulations you got
to be proud of yourself you should be oh
yes very cool and I'm sure Kirby's proud
so very good all right retire inspired
is the book by Chris Hogan and that's
the book on building wealth because
that's your next step now yes there and
we're gonna give you a signed copy of
that in celebration of your debt free
scream thank you number one best-selling
book so enjoy it and all right it's
Nikki from Nashville forty one thousand
dollars paid off in fourteen months
making thirty thousand dollars a year
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
awesomeness very very very cool Wow hey
you can do anything if you decide to you
know are all nightingales old quote from
the 1960s on goal-setting is exactly
right
what you're willing to do to hit your
goal is not nearly as important as what
you're willing to give up to hit your
goal
and that's what Nikki was just talking
about I mean the stuff she gave up she
gave up everything basically for 14
months but you know what she got she got
her life back and she got her the the
sense of dignity that you get when you
take control of stuff like she did that
was so impressive it's a great story
great story thanks for coming by hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a $500,000
in common
you